hello and welcome to another tea session
now what kind of
control am I going to play hmm last one
I even had a classical game in there I
think I'm going to start just with a
couple of you plus two blitz games
let's go deform and see what happens I
got a comment recently I'm not sure like
a week ago or so when somebody said I
would only play patzers here on on D
chess I I really don't know what kind of
perception this person has but as far as
I'm concerned I'm not really like
gaining rating and I mean I don't have
it often that that is true that I play
some somebody with the similar rating
but um you know I don't think I'm
winning every game easily or something
so um I am yeah I'm happy to play here
on this on this platform so we could
Catalan open
the late capture it's probably still
called the open Catalan so a form
and clear white has choice between
Bishop g5 and Bishop f4 mostly I opt for
Bishop g5 I think them
the difference there is mostly
[Music]
um
or is rather unimportant let's say they
don't quite remember how it works here
Rene Queen to c2 or 23
[Music]
yeah I mean even if you forget what
you've looked at I think we'd be three
is right now even if you forget your
theory the typical Catalan middle game
is just so solid it's
to mention how I could be worse
the general idea of this a four-line is
to later occupy the center and now um
yeah I can go if all right
there's no
problem with the small song when to do
it
okay how is he going to play this
problem
some age six
after which I don't want to trade really
by the way if I go 590 590 XD 5
Bishop takes mannered winning c7 here
yeah let's do this spend a long time on
e5 but it looks right huh maybe
so my idea was I take here I mean I
completely disregarded pawn takes t5
because I thought this just just looks
at Russia's but maybe maybe this is
playable after Bishop takes we should be
seven Queen seven Queen c7 I'm winning
in the pawn
I completely forgot that seven is
actually covered
hmmm that's not good
yeah you can give up that pawn on c7
easily at the end of this like Bishop
takes d5 yeah takes here I take here
Queen takes Queen c7 oh really
by the said work
[Music]
you
yeah probably you can play that
yeah I'm paint here so Knight takes
Queen takes
c7 rooks eh somehow works
chess is a weird game sometimes but it
works
yeah then I don't really have anything
here at all
at all
[Music]
Jim made on h7 a quintics kind of forced
I'm always hugely irritated if people
think in such a position obviously due
to this typical engine cheating pattern
I don't think he's doing this but this
is one of those typical things like they
think in positions where there's just
one move but they need the time to enter
into the engine
mm yeah here 97 Roxy 8 is annoying to
say the least
ships his six Roxy seven and I'm losing
material
yeah I have to play this I guess
something
[Music]
something very pedestrian
[Music]
can
perhaps Atia
yeah probably just six maybe he feels
irritated by ninety forty sixty six
possible
you can also play rook c8 is really
nothing wrong about it
you
not a move that I had on the radar
isn't f4 good for white f4 then d5
the problem is c5 is that the queenside
is now extremely weak
so you a more or less has to take I
don't see black allowing d6
how do we play Queen these three maybe
I am rocket Ivana this is good
has to be there anyway and
[Music]
this is the right scream
Eric is fine here okay so I'm move like
Queen f5 is already pretty threatening
so let's do this and I have to pay
attention to the clock
going wiki six year or something like
that
Wow little [ __ ] looks really awful but
maybe this is the move to play
cane
[Music]
I don't I don't see a direct win
something like this is so ready
to play against
even Kareem takes t7 now is probably a
threat
you
the simpler approaches
pretty good and I could as well
give me the Queen
yeah I know I I didn't really understand
how this worked here so instead of
rocket like a normal movers like plus -
yeah I mean this is kind of the position
that you want in this line that's clear
and e5 seems to be bad my main problem
was that I just miscalculated I I
thought yeah I thought he just takes
with the bishop and it's a normal move
to play and what I absolutely did not
see is that if I take this that I'm
actually not attacking b7 really bad now
after this I have to play Queen d6 and
in this position I'm obviously not
better because those pawns are pretty
much yeah in term yeah this is what I
overlooked so ii 5 was clearly ill-timed
so and we had this and now i probably
doesn't don't have anything better than
playing the knight back and I think c5
is a pretty substantial mistake
yeah c6 would be normal of course I have
this but okay black can play Knight b6
to c8 trying to change this or laser
knight on d5 and claim that this is also
a pretty good square on what the engine
suggest simply play queen d8 this is
very very I think instructive in some
way because black is not creating
weakness still preparing the improvement
here and the Queen is bad on g5 anyway
yeah it's it's right there in for f4 or
tempo is always a good move and after c5
I think I'm substantially better right
yeah roughly one pawn and there's a kind
of thing we I expect the engine would
even go higher after a while because
it's probably this is probably not
possible to repair no and so d5 probably
could be a despot a oh yeah are not not
going into the enter this temple because
you don't want to allow the six and this
is yet another tempo
yeahjust rookie one is a good move I
think yeah engine agrees and here
probably a couple of good things Queen
f5 given that rookie six is pretty
reasonable probably not the best move
and now I have to teach you these are
the best according to the compass well
just increasing the pressure
[Music]
yeah I felt that I have to remove this
it's just no more
and resins I mentioned that 20 xd7 could
be an option I think for example here
this is probably winning also I would
think but it's actually not the case
okay I thought what position might even
be so dominant that this could win but
it doesn't it's of course completely
unnecessary with the normal move you win
pretty quickly as we see it as we saw
okay now let's go back to the starting
screen and go for another game I would
even do a rematch but I don't have a
rematch button
oh here bullseye eighty-four SMAP on I
can play before as well
you
okay
you
damp like normally castles or ghosty
five
in the recent
you and she has a yearbook
they looked at Bishop d2 witness
pollution
I really don't understand it when
instead of move actually
Bishop d2 wizened D takes e4 good sorry
bishop takes you three wasn't as good
[Music]
I mean this is what everybody plays and
what I'm going to play and what I have
in my book and so on I just reflected on
this why specialty - I have no clue
you
okay damn the good thing one of the good
things about this line is that
everything else fails and you have no
clear idea what to do we can develop
like the screener 3 Bishop f4 book 81
yeah I guess look anyone
the the long-term ideas to play the
night
night and then play see form I think
night a4 is probably good here right
looks like I might be even able to
build up a dark-squared blockade so he
am yeah the Queen is obviously attacked
I can trade why I can't move the Queen
to d4 and e4 it's not a bad square and
let's do this
you
yeah this is a position where black is
just not equal it's just not entirely
equal because it's poor information on
the queenside
is a little bit a little bit weak
he won possible to UC for the other one
is to jump into c5 I'm going to do that
it was just such a good square yeah and
now you can certainly capture you can
also capture only six this is often
really good option as well but I'm going
for this this is the simpler way to play
now yeah do we go Quincy five
yeah why not
be annoying and say okay how do you get
rid of the Queen
we'll be 6m s what he wants to do
yum I can play
I can play with B form
hmm yeah it's probably still about equal
you
that's why it's still slightly better
impossible tough to say anyway I'm sure
I should play I mean
as I mentioned you don't really
have many sophisticated decisions to
make so I'm not really all that worried
about being a little bit behind on the
clock
you know Matt signals
hey sis defended as well yeah that was
good to trade denied and then Queen to
b6 as good
you
I actually would welcome the
right here because then
some things that
okay nice
nicely done okay
Oh
he's not threatening to Teague of course
and
nice and easy plate as well okay so
let's put the Queen here
okay so what about rook takes is six is
that
yeah of course let's do this
this is definitely close to I mean this
is probably more than enough
compensation for for the pawn
that looks very dangerous
you
okay so have
the rook somehow
we have seven maybe
I can check Anunnaki 5 and tending book
f5 not easy not easy for him
of course I'm threatening rupee 8 with
mage yeah this
I didn't didn't say it but this is the
threat made into rupee eight and so on
and really
I have a hard time to believe really
ow
[Music]
would you kill him
only have little time
a DSP should be six
the check and Bishop h5 was also pretty
interesting and pretty strong
I'm not really seeing a good move for
him anyway
even here I don't see one
okay so
already giving up the Queen Dan row
super threatening
maybe it's not
yeah it's not so clear what this
actually threatens
you
only have seven seconds
you
in g6 is pretty awful now
it was a bit odd right all of a sudden I
got something on the kingside yeah this
is a very typical kind of position from
this opening where black is yeah kind of
okay but it's also not completely equal
as always a little bit annoying to play
and yeah I think of course if he should
age seven hoops that would have won I
didn't look for tactics at all yeah like
what wasn't pretty easy win I was just
looking to improve my position and here
with Queen d6 I spotted this rook takes
his six idea but he has c5 which
completely equalizes I overlooked that
off
yeah okay
and rookie six is probably surprised
wrong in particular in a practical game
and this is already lost
so he has to play this and give me the
c6 pawn I mean I saw this position and
this is kind of a position where white
can basically try without risking much
the bishop he is so nicely anchored
cover c2 covers e - and black doesn't
really have all that much play and I've
got two pawns
so this is pretty nice but this seems to
lose completely rook e1 then probably
here I should play Bishop g6 already
right this this and Bishop h5 is game
over yeah that that was winning
I didn't find it but it's probably
difficult for me to untangle completely
he has to give up the Queen now
and now I finally managed to get design
and he has some majors pretty much
unavoidable I think the plus sixty six
point eight will also be yeah made in
eleven okay so let's go back and play
another one you plus two
my tops 2005
okay
and let's play the session Gogh
usually entertaining games with the
opening don't get this often this the
sharpest variation
III
five
you
Knight f6 now is I think
turret
interesting
I don't really remember how this is
played
it's just like I wonder if 97 is
possible I think if he takes the
exchange I would have pretty strong
compensation let's do this it's an
interesting tribe I also had rook c8 or
stuff like that but it's always tempting
at you for such a dynamic solution now I
go d5
now the immediate ideas to play deform
and after a night move play Bishop h3
okay here I think I have more than one
interesting option
you can think about deform before
was something like age five age five is
the most
dramatic idea just try to kill white
immediately on the kingside
but you can also just castle that is
probably enough for compensation but
okay I like the I like the caveman
approach
I'm not sure
I am curious to try it out and say I'm
not sure if this is really good
okay
yeah let's push this forward
into now Bishop age six I guess
is pretty strong compensation
show about this move actually on second
thoughts now this assist makes no sense
sorry why would you tempt me all the way
to the square that I want to go to
anyway
okay um what now
Jim maybe f5 I just
Step five
Oh for the big guns let's say a five
root g8
the the funniest thing about all this is
that my king is only eight yeah I just
on e eight
okay so I get
the Knights in the attack as well
now threatening 93
this is such a cool position as
[Music]
position that you kill you only get with
the sveshnikov there's just not a single
other opening that would give you this
kind of position
okay um what now if I was attacked
I mean white plate
not sure how to call that but what he
did is he played quickly and this may of
course be important I would definitely
like to have more time in this position
I'm very certain that my position is
pretty pretty good but it's a
of course
not completely easy to play
[Music]
come on I have to be a bit quicker him
maybe he can take and play rook g1 and
defend this stuff
maybe
[Music]
I can also play Bishop c4 here
it's probably not helping okay I have to
be quicker
yeah he's some more defenders hmm ouch
my compensation is kind of dwindling
away
[Music]
what could you want that some
probably simple and good
my queen on a it's not
clearly a half but it doesn't really
help as much as it should
[Music]
or do I get the Queen into the game
don't say come on have to make a move I
know a queen tree it looks odd but my my
king is also
eating the heat a little bit
strange moves but it's okay maybe it's a
good move
you
Oh
yeah Darien for my rookies singing also
I didn't actually see that murukku
singing
I'm losing this game this is so awful
because it was such a nice position and
it was also very good position for sure
I'm very certain that the engine will
give me a winning position now that is
pretty much clear
maybe I'm just too optimistic but I
think it was a really great position
that I had
I'm winning
losing anyway so yeah let's check this
I'm relieved it's a bit annoyed by this
because it must it must have been a
exactly like F 3 and so on this this
cannot go it cannot
why shouldn't really get away with this
one I'm trying to say so okay here this
is not enough yeah night AC to okay with
and mostly I'm thinking about this this
must be good for Mike I mean Bishop age
six
ninety-two latitudes like what
must just win somehow d4 wins okay
[Music]
I mean you have so many attractive moves
and stuff too
it's tough to do tough to decide but
[Music]
you know she ate it's not good divorce
better or efore yeah those tumors win
yeah it's it's it's it's a tough call
it's a tough call but here yeah he's or
here bishop see force is just winning of
course yeah
this is simple this is so simple the
Queen has no squeeze you played this and
it's over right it's just completely
overdue
yeah I'm them now there must have been
some pretty clean win because when white
played so many real moves that that
would never work okay
there Queenie for Asami okay I should
take him I just what I did just didn't
see I said to the group was attacked
yeah I was thinking I take he for play
the knight and the rook is saying so
pretty a pretty badly played okay yeah
we have it Bishop c4 at one stage was
pretty simple and okay you have to see
stuff like that yeah if you play such an
active opening of a material you need to
see some basic tactics if you don't yeah
then you cannot punish we had to be it
moves
okay mainline you over the news ohm
you should take first actually
oh okay it's probably not the end of the
world
[Music]
yeah you don't want to place his six
year
[Music]
okay
the very solid I screwed up the move
over there pretty badly you shouldn't
play age 60
you
you know now I can play this Andy five
position like that is sometimes
completely equal sometimes the better
for white is not trying anything in
particular
yeah this is one of those completely
equal types of positions
but you never know why sometimes can do
stuff in the end game I'm going to move
a king to e7 and ultimately will try to
use be against one the Queen side
and keeps playing
solve a minority attack a bit uncommon
him
you
you
I have to go to e7 with the king anyway
so might do it first and then decide on
on other things
maybe b5 for the move actually for him
I can check him
you
so what white has accomplished
absolutely nothing
and now I'm a little bit better as and
game a little bit because I have a five
and my king is closer to the action
already he lost a bit of time with
others
there's nothing special but it's
a bit annoying for what
you
not completely sure I had this one okay
so let's take
and now what
just approach with the king
libras kingly - okay
I want to go to b5 and pick up that porn
[Music]
you
you
yeah why does some not really
I don't think he has a clear idea how is
holding the special I'm not sure that
there is one but it feels like he's just
like poking around a little bit
now how do we do this I can check
maybe looks similar name it doesn't help
all that much I can't go look a for as
well I wonder if this is
an idea whenever I go up with the key
Nia's root is seven
you
mmm I don't really see him way forward
something like very concrete I don't see
maybe just be 65 if something like that
but
it's very slow
I don't really like to trade away his
weakness down before a bird
it's um
[Music]
see how else I'm going to make any
headway
[Music]
you
that's probably just nothing going on
really
aah rise term fixes weakness and now
maybe use his own rook
James soul
see three doesn't do anything
you probably check first
so come play see three
more than snow I can actually play
[Music]
actually keep it let's do this
if the spawn I mean
you
oh really
I'm surprised
that she allowed this okay now I can go
see three oh I can go around with a king
I think I'm doing this
a king III is probably good hmm okay
II
surprising
I'm just getting this porn alright
we seek keeping it hurts very odd
the pawn
you
you
and I can keep it like that and first
push the pawn a little bit
them
and then I can still give up the g-seven
porn
if I want but I only need to do it
the right moment
or here doesn't matter really
King King to the d-file and promotion
next
you
pretty audio that I just won this
endgame I thought it would be pretty
dead but
you can we can never look them I mean I
think this is just nothing this nothing
happens here
but hehe gave me some stuff that wasn't
really necessary like so King f3 York is
7 like this this is still ok I think but
now some some weird things happen now he
he checked me there and pushed me to
that was strange
maybe not decisive here so before I yes
I agree with that and now we are just
King III and what happens there I don't
think I've got anything if I was just or
if he does that I probably play King
rookie sceptic his 7 and then we just
then it just stays like that and it's a
draw after e5 it's immediately lost it
seems yeah man let's just see if I did
something terrible they are I don't
think so it's difficult to screw it up
so he basically just blundered the book
ending away okay I think one more game
certainly possible
one and now
Oh No Carlos Grillo okay
I can go see for more so all the main
moves in the session
three
now taking a while okay three
like is
like a king's indian set okay okay here
you have many ideas going for the quick
inside lay with B form
oh really
it is a bit odd
of course the what Vinick setup is is
fine I mean I've recommended it there
are multiple occasions but this is not
one of those good cases for the but
Vinick
some control over the center here is
really good
and okay now I have to take I don't want
you have the bishop outside there and
then all of a sudden there's no squares
so I'm going from before now like II
cannot easily play b5 because of the
long diagonal
and the rucas hanging
it seems that d5 is on blacks agenda
understandably so now can we or should
we just ignore this and play b5 or
the move Queen b3 usually looks like a
good idea to stop the fire but it may be
has b5 then
doesn't look on that grade
so if we have be 5 instead be 5 d5
okay it seems playable
it really seems playable
[Music]
you
I can prevent d5 with Quincy one just
for the moment
she takes Knight takes Knight takes
Queen see 197 shakers the idea
you
basically one movie a Quincy one
but I needed I needed just a I needed a
move that I could make
and that I did not quite
immediately could refute so Quincy one
ultimately played
you can of course try to increase this
control over the five and play
this one
stop preparing or maybe yeah let's play
this now when
yes I don't want to lose some time here
by trying to get a little something
there and then I get to little something
there then I've lost some time
yeah maybe d5 is playable ent 5c takes
night eggs
I can take with the bishop actually okay
now here can take of course let's do
this and now what about it should be
seven here on
or hook p7 those moves are certainly
possible Bishop e7 would just win a six
I think
now it looks it looks very unharmonious
so activating the queen
and just look at a six seven
[Music]
still just to be porn
one important point you see is that the
bishop on g7 is absolutely not
um participating in the game that is
important
so I'm basically trying to play on the
queenside with extra material as sg7 is
such a non piece and the servants
configuration so kind of curious what
he's doing now
maybe studi 5 get rid of the DVD 6 bond
I can take
honey
a very dubious
giving me the square
five is not possible at all
I'm getting a little bit closer also to
this ideal scenario when 95 where if I
can trade everything off and at the end
there's a knight on d5 on a bishop on d5
against the bishop on g7 this is a
strategic strategic dream right
the first problem is said that a five is
just doomed I guess
don't see how he keeps the spawn
you
I'm just I'm just
marriage to the idea to
keep this Bishop a dummy
I had beforehand as pollution that's
something that I should have spotted
you
okay now how do we how do we play this
is very entertaining
because that can absolutely move it's no
active whatsoever
[Music]
okay probably
during d5 for the night
do I really have to I think I have to
when they exchange you don't want to
give up your fantastic night on the fire
but it's too tempting
- just now
gained material
you
now we can have a look that I think I
will look at a couple of things there
interesting position is this one
well I wasn't really sure what you do
quincy one is probably not really ooh
after a while it's the engine move
interesting
oh okay
it stops d5 I mean that was my idea for
the moment okay
so root is seven and then I went to be
five hear the engine wants to go if
force one of the moves I've thought
about that I mean this is not totally
ridiculous because you're just making
very sure that this doesn't happen but
it looked I didn't want to do that
a kilo of this beautiful bishop
okay I went b5 and now he can actually
play d5 and this is probably just equal
so C takes Knight takes him Bishop takes
Bishop takes Knight takes
you know this trades down to absolutely
nothing ham okay this is yd 5 isn't good
but he didn't do that so I took
and queen a3 and now it gets more
difficult and now I still think as yeah
as I said I think during the game you
should probably just play d5 um I had
what I thought is
she didn't see that Bishop age three I
didn't see now
mmm I thought I'd just take a 6
basically him which is not enough but
Eric fc-1 is also a good move so I still
have something there but a 5 is really
bad
I mean this is bad no you don't get get
your your porn pushes in absolutely not
yeah this is too early I should move the
Queen something like that because I
think I mentioned that he had efore now
and that is that that he has to play
absolutely now
this breaks this configuration and there
might still be a bit better because I
get to d5 with the knight ultimately but
this is of course a huge achievement for
black that you can get rid of this is
pawn and maybe later can activate the
bishop after okay eight now I'm just in
time to keep everything covered
yeah and this is absolute disaster
seven yeah this is some kind of a
typical game for this type of line I was
a bit shocked about c5 because this is a
pretty hot spot for this kind of
formation because you usually don't want
this bishop to immediately being able to
pin the knight and trade it trade for
this because then White has three pieces
for the control over d5 and black only
two and this often at the end leads to
this kind of scenario as we at the end
saw here yeah a knight against a bad
piece so I got the ideal scenario at the
end after some yeah adventures let's say
where black could have played better on
multiple occasions yeah thanks a lot for
watching bye bye